alors bonjour à la planète ici stéphane
parent en direct des studios de radio
canada international et de radio canada
à montréal et gm en compagnie toute une
équipe je vous salue ici sur ma caméra
personnelle m'aide dans la caméra ce
groupe c le groupe qu'importe à cette
émission de tomtom canada israël ou
d'assinco bonjour ici c'est devenu une
habitude
et puis allez chantal jean d'esme
également ces gens là ne sont pas
obligés de se présenter à l'émission met
au travail
oui c'est bien sûr c'est toujours une
faveur qui lui font lorsqu'ils viennent
pas passé une partie de leur journée de
travail c'est un en studio pour avoir du
plaisir avec nous où on nous ont fait
découvrir le canada à tout le monde même
aux québécois et puis marie-claude de
simard est avec nous bonjour narry close
c'est notre web mais du côté français
francophones
et puis web os du côté de la section de
l'équipe latino américaine c'est notre
copain léo gimeno bonjour des eaux la
ola je parlerai pas parce que ça fait
trois mois qu'on vous a pas vu vous 2 à
l'émission une mission qui requiert 2
webmestre pourtant des tatas on est là
félicitations alors les applaudit oui
y'a pas grand chose qui a changé à cette
formule gagnante de l'émission durant
l'été c'est toujours la même chanson
on commence par la devinette la vidéo 5
images pour devenir devenir pour deviner
ensemble quel est le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui ceux qui nous regardent en
direct lors des diffusions ce vendredi
peuvent également jouer avec nous les
autres savent de quoi il retourne
aujourd'hui sur le site web ils voient
tous attendent premières images le thème
aujourd'hui dès que vous sentez que vous
êtes sur quatre ans le gras trans et une
bonne idée ça banni par le canada cette
semaine
situation d'urgence on dirait un bel
avion dans l'intérieur d'un cockpit
le comme les tempêtes les tempêtes
pourquoi vous dites tempête lorsqu'il ya
personne n'y a personne tu le monde est
regardé les oreilles
regardez ça va apparaître au haut de
l'écran et oui on avait tenté de masquer
la réalité bien sûr vite et que vous
répondez correctement à la première
image c'est quand même ennuyeux pour
tout le monde quand vous le faites
jamais produit ça c'est une image
l'ouragan comment il s'appelle florent
laurent comment elle s'appelle se sont
elles sont toujours des femmes je pense
c'est permis oui on s'est permis des
parce que c'est là le secteur oui doit
vivre des règles où il ya des règles je
sais pas si c'est une fin abrupte mais
j'en suis sûr
lorsqu'on propose souvent des questions
auxquelles on n'a pas réponse en début
d'émission même en fin d'émission pour
ça qu'on a besoin d'un spécialiste et
avant d'aller vers le spécialiste on
regarde la vidéo numéro 2 si vous
permettez parce que on va parler
seulement d'une chose aujourd'hui va pas
parler dix typhons parce que les typhons
sait dans quelle zone du monde
c'est devant vous la l'examen c'est en
asie oui puis le long du pacifique
pacifique ouest nord ouest
on va pas parler des cyclos non plus
j'avais pas ça je pensais que discours y
en avait partout mais non c'est
seulement dans l'océan indien
on va parler de quoi des bien sûr parce
que nous on ira du canada est en
national où on ne l'est pas ça c'est des
ouragans j'ai appris quelque chose il ya
une dizaine de jours lorsqu'on parlait
d'un ouragan qui atterrissait sur les
côtes de d'hawaii j'ai dû moi landon en
ouragan dans le pacifique
et oui dans le pacifique est ce que
quelqu un des meilleurs vieux que moi
dans quelle région du pacifique général
très fortement des préventions d'être
professeur de parler du sol non il reste
le centre est
on peut refaire rejouer l'image
ct liu centre-est à pacific est ce
centre oui presque
c'était de bons yeux bouffis ben oui
alors moi je rêve est fini de répondre
aux questions
ça y est c'est le premier jeu de la
grosse boule aujourd'hui première manche
20 points à 3 jeux à l'émission à chaque
manche on gagne des points
supplémentaires en espère avoir 100%
comme à l'essence même est un défi à
relever j'aime concentré cette année ou
combien la semaine dernière ça fait deux
semaines que j'ai zéro et puis ça fait 3
trois semaines que je devrais prince à
20 j'ai eu 4 iv non mais il al habitude
de gagner
non mais aujourd'hui je me sens premier
en question dans le golfe du mexique et
tout le long de la côte est nord
américaine
quand la saison des ouragans commence
t'elle et se termine tel donc de quel
mois qu'elle mois ce dur cette saison
des ouragans vous faut être le plus
proche de la bonne réponse pour emporter
les 20 points de quel mois et quelle moi
la saison des ouragans un tel lieu le
long de la côte est américaine et dans
le golfe du mexique entre novembre et
février 9 en février de vendre à février
oui l'heure est au mois deux sa part le
7 décembre août à décembre
moi je voulais dire ou à novembre aussi
ou à novembre inclusivement jusqu'au 30
novembre évidemment donc vous y allez
c'est plus court pour vous que celui
pour alice d'accord voulait au jeu cela
marche
vous voulez vous pourriez remporter tous
les points parce que si vous êtes si
elle avait les points ci est là mais non
vous auront apporté ton vous passez de
la même chose donc un fait faire des
voyages mange jamais voyagé
amérique centrale mais c'est toujours
comme vous voyagez dans la saison des
ouragans
alors c'est rapport à l'actualité
généralement on en parle dès le mois
d'août et ça se termine vers la mi
décembre
je pense que dans le fond des choses
vous allez pendant deux raisons parce
que l'on parle des ouragans qui affecte
le de la météo canadienne
il arrive un peu plus tardivement dans
la saison mais la saison officielle des
ouragans
tout pays qu'ont compris les états unis
mexique et canada
c'est en fait de ça se termine au mois
de novembre
d'accord c'est bien et ça commence mal
et non juste avant au mois de juin qui
est le plus proche des bonnes réponses
alors comme vous n'êtes aucun d'entre
vous des spécialistes en moi là dessus
loin de là moi non plus le voici le
voilà simon legault qui métérologue de
sensibilisation aux alertes à la
direction des services de prévision
ministères environnement et changement
climatique canada
bonjour simon d'envoyer votre votre
paquetage de 20 voix est énorme expliqué
si on commençait par vous qui êtes le
spécialiste lorsque vous avez vu
florence passé comme ça sur les côtes
nord américaines
est-ce que vous avez une réaction une
opinion plus éduqués que les simples
mortels comme nous vous aviez une une
quelque chose qui faisait a encore où
quelque chose parce que depuis un
certain temps on va garder les
dépressions le sait des choses qu'on
suit quand même régulièrement vous le
dis dans la période de juin à novembre
c'est la période active au niveau de
l'atlantique donc on regarde si on
regarde les prisons qui sont faites à
partir du centre de prévision des
ouragans aux etats-unis dans et donc on
peut après se projeter avec les modèles
météo ou est ce que c'est
je regardais devrait se déplacer pendant
un certain temps
quelques jours plus tôt ont été capables
de savoir qu'il se passerait quelque
chose mais vous savez que ça va prévoir
les trajectoires des ouragans et jours
d'essai compliqué il faut faire soi ou
du mauvais temps qui passe au dessus de
mourir parce que c'est une tempête en ce
moment là on a dit qu'on nous annonce
des vents de 90 km au dessus de montréal
ah je sais pas à quelle heure exactement
je pense que c'est déjà pas mal commencé
ce genre de tempête est ce que c'est ils
liés à aux effets homo ce qui reste de
florence
non pas du tout dans clarence ses formes
est plutôt mal moi il ya déjà si tu
écoutes sans mandat
on vous entend pas tant bien que mal
ouais on a perdu dont on a perdu la pole
à la dernière est à terre on ne vous
entend plus près tout ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va convaincu et ça on va
rappeler qu'on va arrêter la connexion
avec skype puis on voit là dans quelques
heures je le vois pas mais des yeux donc
je pense qu'il devrait nous entende en
principe reprendre quelques secondes
quand même parce que c'est un beau pari
du mauvais temps il faut le faire avec
des mauvaises conditions pour regarder
un film joue sur netflix
je vais vous demander parce que c'est
très personnel tout ça avez vous déjà
pensé à travers une méchante tempête ou
en ouragan dans votre vie faire le tour
de table aux autres objets notamment des
ventes et comme des histoires de pêche
mais on vous écoute
ben oui j'ai passé papa un ouragan mais
une très forte tempête
en guadeloupe entre marie galante et la
guadeloupe
un bateau qui fait le trajet une heure
les gens criaient c'était terrible
fallait pas avoir le mal de mer et on
est arrivé quand même à bon port la
preuve je suis ici mais avec une petite
frayeur
ça a duré plusieurs heures le temps du
trajet 55 minutes passent et tous mes 45
minutes qui durent très longtemps car
quand on traverse une tempête
vous voyez pas grand chose il vient
juste des grosses vagues qui tapait sur
les fenêtres et les gens qui criaient
vive votre musculation travail vous
pensez aux prochains bulletins de
nouvelles annonces à quelque chose être
sous l'eau un on sait jamais qu est ce
qui peut arriver mais bon le bateau a
tenu on est arrivé à bon port mais la
frayeur était je n'avais jamais vécu
aussi intensément et ce n'est pas un
ouragan je me suis dit ouh la la qu'est
ce que ça doit être quand un ouragan
frappe les caraïbes en plus c'est
monsieur le groupe excusez moi monsieur
legault vous nous entendez parfait on
est sur du plus joli de pardon peut vous
parler donc il faut à l'époque du cha li
qu'on disait stop à toutes les cinq
secondes parce qu'on voulait pas perdre
trop de signal avec vous je voulais vous
demander
il ya lorsqu'on parle des ouragans des
trajectoires tout seul j'entends
toujours à la télévision parce que je
regarde seulement mes informations la
télévision c'est bien du bien connu que
on a le modèle américain qui prédit
telle chose le modèle européen qui
prédit telle chose je soupçonne qu'un
modèle canadien quelque part
effectivement donc on a un modèle qu'on
épingle au bal qui fait une prévision au
niveau de la planète entière et on est
des modèles plus un jeunot encore les
modèles qu'on appelle régional et même 1
er limité donc est encore plus près ici
mes souvenirs beaucoup plus petite au
niveau 2 du cac pourquoi est ce que ces
modèles sont fondamentalement différent
où ils approchent il aborde la question
de façon différente mathématiquement où
ils ont des ordinateurs plus puissants
plus performant dans certaines zones je
ne sais pas parler tout ça
j'utilise les mêmes données de base donc
la soirée d'observation dans les
stations météo observations satellites
et des radars
donc toutes sortes d'observation qui
sont collectés mais la façon de les
traiter vos différents ils vont
organiser un ordinateur donc oui chaque
centre de privat utiliser l'ordinateur
spécialisé super ordinateur pour pouvoir
utiliser ces modèles météo et des
modèles vont utiliser des paramètres des
équations différentes légèrement
différente ce que donnait parfois
justement les différences qu'on peut
percevoir encore les prévisions météo et
ces prévisions doivent être
régulièrement sont mises à jour
régulièrement
donc on a juste tout le temps les
prévisions maintenant il ya des modèles
où il vous le disiez à travers le monde
des modèles américains canadiens
européens est un modèle en france chez
des modèles en angleterre il y en a au
japon en australie dans un gain des
modèles un peu partout donc on a un
problème technique
je pense qu'il a cinq enfants - un
policier de l'image
des métiers du groupe on peut appeler au
téléphone
très bonne idée je vous appelle tout de
suite monsieur locaux puis pendant qu'on
fait ça je pense qu'il est très
important de montrer des images de
laurent florence deygas moi je retiens
pas mis ce que formation la télévision
je faisais des blagues
je suis seulement sur le sommet sur les
tablettes et puis sur téléphone portable
donc je vois pas grand chose parce que
ça coûte trop cher en donnant données
donc j'ai pas vu des images d'image mais
sauf celle ci que j'ai moi même j'ai
fait le montage cette semaine dix
matches qui viennent de syrie si nous
maintenons voilà alors s'assure le gain
du journaliste qui n'osent pas reculer
devant danger garance vers l'eau mais là
on voit vite à manquer du vampire de
look avance ça me fait penser au
phénomène de chasseurs d'eau vague ces
personnes où ils vont se positionner
d'ici qui sont pas de la meilleure image
possible je me demande toujours comment
il faut selon les espaces et les
policiers les l'espace la première est
bien sûr alors il ya eu 30 man tu t'en
un peu plus puis évidemment nous au
canada on a déjà eu des histoires où il
ya eu des morts plus de 80 morts le 90
l'année à ça je vous le dis pas parce
qu'elle veut faire partie d'une question
de savoir si en général bientôt votre
tour de répondre à ces fameuses
questions posées vous avez le sujet de
l'émission
oui vous pouvez faire une recherche en
direct et trouve une question et que je
devrais répondre correctement
[Rires]
voilà et puis là je pense qu'on peut
montrer la vidéo numéro attends je vous
donne des chiffres on va regarder la
numéro 2 numéro 4 ça ça nous mentent le
centre canadien de prévision des
ouragans donc est un service conax à
celui où travaille notre ami essayant
logo
monsieur le corps vous nous entendez
bien très bien
le centre le centre canadien de
prévision des ouragans dont on a parlé
est-ce qu'il est situé au même endroit
où vous travaillez ou le gars le canada
était étant tellement grand c'est donc
dans la région une des régions les plus
touchées page demandée au ragga donc
nous on n'est pas resté à montréal et
vous ayez raison que des bureaux
répartis au canada
il est temps de recherche météo se
retrouve vers montréal ce que je trouve
admirable ici c'est que notre équipe
technique à l'image à conserver l'image
mais utilise le sens du téléphone
vraiment leur champion
la technologie c'est pierre techniciens
présents travaux juste une petite
question à simon silhouette que dans
l'histoire du canada on a eu des
passages des ouragans avec des
conséquences aussi je veux dire
dévastatrice que celle qu'on observe sa
dernière année et après comme tout est
comme geler les provinces atlantiques
donc pas vraiment la nouvelle-écosse
période et tous est souvent touchée par
les tempêtes look sont souvent plus les
ouragans mais que tous les tempêtes
extra-tropicales donc ils y ont perdu sa
femme karité le pq mais des ouragans
mais peuvent toujours mais le même genre
de dommage donc il va lui parce que la
majorité des serbes des thons
occasionnées par les ouragans et surtout
par les inondations la pluie
donc oui on est en fait assez est
rigoureuse mais quand même rien à
comparer avec laurent c'est qu'on a
dominé par tous est enlevé dans le texte
qui va mieux aussi beaucoup d'eau le
doit qu'à la dette ou six touchés par
des restants de tusson donc il ya des
années où il y répond donc lis les posts
tempête se déplace jusqu'à
colombie-britannique et permet aussi à
sa fin de match du groupe e de courant
des grands-vents donc je n'ai pas de
côté ou r2 est donné
une toute dernière question étant donné
que les spécialistes établissent un
certain parallèle entre ces phénomènes
là et les changements climatiques
est ce que dans les années à venir on
devrait craindre que le canada vivent un
phénomène apocalyptique avec
l'apocalypse est enfin mehdi dommage ou
les changements sont à prévoir
si on pense aux changements climatiques
en fait globalement avec une rose du
niveau de la mer d'un les ondes de
tempête qui accompagne souvent ces
organes dont utilise donc doit être un
peu plus élevé ton qui selon la tour
risque d'être plus important qu'aux si
on s'attend à voir aussi une
augmentation des cas de précipitation
donc environ 10% de plus de
précipitations assez proche de la
tempête
donc on lui demande s'il a un impact qui
veut jouer encore les inondations
cependant on sait ce qui aurait
peut-être moins d'ouragans donc une
sonde du nombre de requins mets sucrés
devraient en moyenne un peu plus fort
donc un livre monsieur plupart et donc
on aura un impact côte à côte des
canadiens ou encore le don de se
détendre falloir regarder à plus long
terme il n'y aura qu'un bon une issue
qui s'est passé récemment qui semble
qu'on était au fait que lille aura qu'un
sangle c'était un peu plus lentement en
moyenne donc ils ont attend la pluie
abondante et ont un plus on envoie
restait donc encore une vision
fragmentée des inondations et il est
très exactement pour est différent pour
sega nous donc on pourrait les formes un
peu plus loin contenant amérique et donc
nos séries souvent c'est presque un
mètre plus loin et là encore je touche
un peu moins souvent la terre dont il
traitait plus puissant mais plus loin au
large des côtes et qu'on aura une époque
en café du rêve à lui d'un vin horizon
de quelques décennies les eaux
oui en fait deux questions je me les
savoirs se
comment est-ce que ces formes unis la
gauche puis la deuxième comment
commencer forme comment est ce qu'on y
commence ni légale ni la deuxième
question c'est pourquoi les différences
dénoncent-ils et l'édition les choses
sont à peu près la même chose mais dans
une côte et s'appelle typhon dans une
côte et s'appelle le cycle opinion c'est
le cas pourquoi les la différence donc
des flics tropicaux et selon les régions
du monde et ils ont d'énormes ferrain
donc ouragans celia le nom pour à cannes
je crois qu'il devait environ par les
peuples indigènes des gares et donc
c'était donc un langage parlé avant même
l'arrivée des européens dont qu'ils font
c'est un nom qui donnez combien le plus
touristique ma pour les clubs nord ouest
du pays
donc ils vont être surtout philippines
japon la semaine sur console c'est aussi
par la main ferme locale mais si c'est à
la base c'est le même phénomène météo
maintenant commencé comme une tempête
tropicale comme s'ils s'y plonge sans
parler d'un gardien de base dont on le
sait en soit on peut dire que ça prend
de nous ce n'est pas la surface de juin
à 28 29 degrés sur le c1 dont se sont
servis profondeur on parle d'un général
22 grille pour avoir profité du christ
et scousers ensuite on doit avoir des
conditions propices
on doit avoir de l'air un peu plus froid
à l'aide pour pouvoir crier leur rage
contre être fait par tous donc un oeil
sur les gangs espère aider à passer
d'une tempête
ensuite on va voir une perturbation qui
va arriver souvent pour les ouragans
peuvent arriver souvent le continent
africain
donc on peut avoir sur des temps d'orage
ou une zone 2 un peu de la divergence
est donc la deuxième destination au
niveau de la surface donc la souris mais
de nouveau les tromper comme celui au
nom de la charia avec l'eau chaude et
humide si donc on va les vapeurs attaque
mais cet ambre et donc on va avoir une
montée de la guinée dans le parcours du
nuage lancer une blanche s'est créé un
peu plus haut un atmosphère
donc le nuage se comptent l'agglo se
condense on a un relâchement des
chaleurs comparativement à qui on le
sait les faire bouillir de l'eau de
faire évaporer de louie fournée de
l'énergie met donc fait le phénomène
inverse se condense libèrent de
l'énergie camp libéral énergie on
réchauffe encore plus encore plus de
passes et l'atmosphère on déstabilise
encore plus et l'a donc la conviction se
met plus fort donc plus en profondeur et
c'est le début de la tempête
maintenant si on se trouve trop près de
l'équateur on n'aura pas le phénomène de
rotation qui a des oreilles africaine à
l'extérieur de l'équateur donc au nom
d'environ 112 de grille de lecture et
l'on pourra engendrer la synchronisation
donc le fait que ça tourne dans le sens
antihoraire novacap donc c'est le même
qui va générer mairie sorte de grille
rasées dans le cinéma
il ya un grand appétit là il m'a donc
une différence de 20 ans directeur ou en
vitesse entre la surface et un plus haut
en atmosphère donc le vendre comme
couper la tempête donc ça pour justement
diminuer le nombre de tempêtes dans une
période et l'union des hausses étaient
vraiment la question la [ __ ] à terme
la plus la réponse la plus intéressante
comprendre un phénomène quand même mais
moi j'avais une question évidemment les
autorités compétentes classe les la
force des ouragans d'1 à cinq je crois
puis là j'ai lu dernièrement que parce
que les ouragans deviennent de plus en
plus fort rouleur surface leurs
superficies sont de plus en plus énormes
on penserait à une catégorie 6 est ce
que c'est vrai ce que vous pouvez
confirmer cette information
tropical des pouvoirs et des débats tant
qu'hôpital ans du club on commence avec
un temps avec une tempête tropicale ses
vents soutenus
donc c'est pas les rappeurs médisants
soutenu nous - 64 km ha et là on va
donner le nom à la tempête tropicale en
tenant le rôle jouera bien le niveau 1
au niveau 2 niveau 3 et du bouquin les
bottins qu'étant le plus
les adhérents soutenus de 250 kilomètres
les plus forts donc j'arrive peuvent
également il ya eu l'année passée il y
en a pas eu deux dernières différences
dans le niveau car il était le seul qui
était glacée ouaga majeurs juste
derrière 2010 donc j'ai pas entendu de
nouvelles catégories qui pourraient
dernière donne la dernière que nous que
vous vous êtes pas encore prononcé je
pense que je voulais savoir qu'est ce
que vous pensez du rôle des médias dans
quand on parle des ouragans par exemple
dans la prévision des ouragans parce que
souvent on anticipe avec les médias que
ça va plus rien mettre très fort et puis
on prévoit toutes sortes de choses on
annonce plus toutes sortes de choses
finalement l'ouragan bon cause des
dommages évidemment mais heureusement
fort heureusement c'est pour spir qu'on
prévoyait est-ce que vous vous sentez
que les médias c'est quoi en fait le
rôle qu'ils ont à jouer ce qui cause un
peu de sous c'est important d'en parler
vraiment d'avant sous oui c'est qu'on ne
lit l'organisme gens qui font au niveau
de communication mais les gens veulent
être plus branché à la télévision il a
eu l'air toutes les applications dont on
voit la communication qui a amplifié par
les mets devant xavier louy joue un rôle
important par rapport à tribune est et
nous allons prendre action parce qu'il
sait maintenant qu'une 13 en plus
d'avoir même plutôt grâce aux médias
quand ça vient amplifier le message ou
angela portée du message que les autres
c'est bon lancer maintenant que des
milieux se déplace dans la dentelle et
viennent prendre cela en compte est bon
personne de se retrouver dans le forez
pour mille déplacés non plus à pittem
attendons des rapports des objets les
mandats sont contents de crue d'éclat
dont notamment maintenant ça peut être
dangereux pour tout le monde mais les
maisons aux abonnements 1 ap en pause sa
part à ce nouvel os donc par rapport à
la communication de juristes africains
pas seulement des bains en classe nous
aurions fonction 2020 uniquement et non
pas en fonction des dommages causés par
soit l'on doit pas être soit par la
pluie
donc c'est vraiment une puisque ce
message totalement bali bêtement avec la
catégorie 2 l'ouragan s'il est avec toi
tu es venu ici parce que je n'avais pas
que se concentraient en dehors de ces
dernières heures
oui dans le fond ma question concerne le
processus d'attribution des
dénominations aux ouragans
généralement on va entendre parler de
florence de rita non c'est à croire que
c'est les femmes qui sont les plus
méchantes dans cette affaire harvey
c'était un homme le wii speak
il est le nom est ouverte et parle déjà
rallié les autorités américaines ou des
plus tôt une alternance entre hommes des
femmes à une banque de long qui donnait
d'années après allez on va dire à
entendre le maintenant venise et déjà eu
un ouragan car en fin de partie
ils seront retirés de la banque pourra
gagner fait beaucoup de dommages qu une
grande dévastation îles marquises à
vendre plus reprendre ce nom là à partir
du moment où il a été utilisé une fois
où ça va marquer mais on peut parfois
entendre mais non mon arrivée comme des
passifs déjà eu une autre ne pourra
gagner plus tôt on sait ça peut arriver
les autorités américaines qui décide en
alternant des noms amis rythme en tant
que femmes et hommes et femmes halde un
rythme puisque ce sont les américains
qui décident ou andrew se trouve sur la
liste l'ouragan donald stupide de la
catastrophe suffisent à écouter sinon ce
fut un plaisir de vous poser toutes ces
dernières questions à la prochaine
pourquoi c'est simon legault métérologue
de sensibilisation aux alertes à la
direction des services de prévision au
ministère environnement et changement
climatique canada
donc je suppose qu'on ne verra plus le
nom katrina d'intérêt alors écoutez on
est prêt pour le deuxième manche de
notre jeu populaire oui alors comme vous
n'avez pas poser toutes les questions il
reste encore pour des questions la
grosse boule aujourd'hui d'avoir jeu
compliquer un peu les choses que c'est
trop facile trop facile jusqu'à
maintenant
non pas celle là il y en a il y en a
trois par émission hockey parfait mais
lui il est
6 à 7 au 15 juin demande à la personne
si des questions déjà été réduits
pourquoi répondu qu'il n'était pas chère
social c'est arrivé une fois que
quelqu'un pourrait poser la question que
j'allais poser depuis stade plus jamais
voici deuxième manche
c'est bon pour 30 points quel
pourcentage des ouragans apporte non
seulement de la pluie mais aussi des
précipitations sous forme de chutes de
neige un ouais parce que je n'ai pas
parlé
oui alors quel pourcentage selon vous
des ouragans apporte non seulement de la
pluie mais aussi des précipitations sous
forme de deux prêts sur une image
d'ouragan avec souffle jusqu'au mois de
novembre il ya des tempêtes de neige des
fois alors quel pourcentage lui qui le
plus proche de la bonne réponse
pourtant je dirais 10 % 10 % très bien
alice 5% à 5% qui dit mieux
au moment où il y avait de la neige bas
des gens que ça se transforme en cyclone
pas vraiment je dirais 27% à 7 7%
c'est pas très scientifique sous la
pression qui a 30 points un examen qui a
tramp en examen la réponse c zéro pour
ça
les masses d'air chaud qui est la neige
on s'est fait avoir c'est ça c'est là
c'est celle là comme la dernière les
dernières passage ça a été formé quand
même d'un tempête tropicale mais ça
monte puis peut-être ça peut-être ces
héros pour ça pour autant même plus tôt
c'est vrai je vous prête la dorna
mais j'aimerais qu'on fasse y est vous
avez 50 ans ont fait ou est ce que vous
avez à ces gens tu es ce que vous avez
déjà vu une tempête de neige avec des
orages non - oui en argentine on ici
combien de fois une seule fois assister
au quai piétons mais la neige vraiment
intense ils ont donc tu mérites 30
points merci d'avoir été témoin d'un
phénomène il ya souvent des disputes en
fin d'émission pour savoir qu'il est le
grand gagnant parce que j'avais 50 à 0
au tour mais oui mais quelle chance
jeumont a pas droit de tricher en plus
je voulais vous demander
dernière question mais bonne pour 50
points celle là bas et elle est plus
sérieuse d'un carnet c'est moins drôle
c'est plus sérieux mais ça montre
l'impact que peuvent avoir les ouragans
question qui porte une ombre de décès au
canada en raison de ces du passage de ce
qui reste du zinc alors sur les terres
canadiennes l'ouragan à l'origine du
plus grand nombre de décès et l ouragan
et ce au nom d'une femme encore qui
s'est produit en 1954 à l'époque c'est
avec des femmes qui faisait figure de
l'ouragan
alors réseau va causer la mort de 80 une
personne dite moi dans quelle province
se trouvaient ses 81 canadiens décédés
dans quelle province
la nouvelle écosse vegas je dirai la
même chose
la même chose parce que tu entends
parler de lui
c'est à dire eh oui je mélange pas avec
des tornades on aurait pu demander
l'heure et je change de sujet s'est
détendu l'été prochain il tourne à la
bataille
le labrador ouais le labrador et à terre
neuve et labrador mais finalement c'est
halifax et non non nouvelle écosse
nouvelle écosse a fait bon alors on va
falloir me dire qui est le plus proche
de la bonne réponse
ok géographiquement parlant ça peut-être
demain une recherche l'ordinateur je
n'ai pas la réponse mois à j la réponse
réponse mais j'ai pas la réponse ce qui
est le gagnant ou la gagnante
d'accord c'est en ontario que ça si tu
veux tu arrives en ontario au niveau des
grands lacs
c'est le passage de l'ouragan un effet
de rebond mais sa cotation et noyelles
c'est en ontario c'est pas dans une des
promesses de marassi maritime
je pense qu on veut connaître la
distance entre la saskatchewan est lancé
moi je pense qu'on est proche et plus
proche
ben oui c'est ça ou en ontario mais où
sont vendues entre grands lacs
jean des grands lacs lac erie dans ce
coin là c'est l'école ou à peu près on
se partage tous les points alors un camp
divisé par quatre moi je suis d'accord
pour ça mais oui parce que ce serait
comme ça lui l'argent quand il y en a
beaucoup d'autres une autre plus de sept
ans à l'engagement bah oui tout le monde
y est
parce que généralement c'est le patron
qui se taillent ça dépend des
entreprises
tu connais pas hydro one si on partage
équitablement à l'autre bout au sujet
des missions à chaque fois que je viens
ici on se donnait des idées d'un chrono
vraiment merci beaucoup alors grande
gagnante c'est tout le monde surtout
vous partage les points je ne sais
jamais on a tous participé alors tout le
monde a gagné merci n est ce pas
l'inversé
mercialys merci à vous merci merci marie
claude et puis les eaux on dit bonjour
un camion soir mais la suite de bail